[Music]
on this episode of travel dare season s
i'm digging below the surface to learn
more about the country's tallest and
deepest underground waterfall
[Music]
last episode i received a clue about
where i'd end up on this episode you'll
have to go underground to see this tall
beauty in person so now i'm here in
chattanooga to go see one of its most
iconic destinations ruby falls as you
can see the views are incredible from
the edwin hotel looking over at the
walnut street bridge while the views are
stunning from above i can't wait to
learn more about this appalachian wonder
that sits below the surface
so this is my first time in chattanooga
i am loving it i have been to a cave
i've been to a waterfall but i've never
been to a waterfall in a cave i am so
pumped to see what that is all about
hi i'm grant i'm going to be your tour
guide today i'm jenna welcome to ruby
falls nice to meet you for having me our
pleasure we're excited to have you so
right now we are standing on top of the
80-foot lookout mountain tower we'll go
260 feet down into the cave and then
it's about a half mile walk and by the
time we get to the falls we'll be at
1120 feet under the summit of lookout
mountain yeah that's amazing ruby falls
is the tallest and deepest underground
waterfall that's open to the public in
the united states and we were discovered
by accident by our founder leo lambert
in 1928 he was actually digging into the
mountain to find another cave that he
knew about below ruby falls and they
accidentally ran into the vein through
the mountain that led them to ruby falls
and so it was just kind of a happy
accident yeah that's a cool thing the
rest is history yeah absolutely
absolutely and then he named it after
his high school sweetheart uh ruby as
well oh that's so sweet he followed from
indiana here yeah oh my gosh i love that
as a matter of fact when leo lambert and
his crew first discovered ruby falls
they actually had to crawl for six hours
before they got to a point where they
could even stand up in the cave
and all together it took them about 17
hours to get there and back so it's much
easier for us today it only takes about
an hour and a half so you ready to do
this i'm so ready all right let's go
all right we are now descending 260 feet
deep into the heart of lookout mountain
this rock you see in front of here is
limestone and cool thing about that the
limestone that was excavated out of this
elevator shaft is what was used to build
the cavern castle that we were just in
here oh these are for us yeah absolutely
pick one
okay
pretty excited about getting to wear
this today is your lucky day all right
lights on you ready to go yes all right
let's do it
so this whole cave at one point water
was flowing through it
and is what carved out most of it now
again probably about waist down
you can see where they had carved out
the path so we can walk upright
comfortably and i'm for one i'm very
grateful that they did
[Music]
oh what's that that is our cactus and
candle formation
i was going to say it looks like a
cactus yeah yeah so it was basically
formed by water dripping through the
limestone cap in the ceiling and it
slowly deposited minerals here for
hundreds of years just very slowly about
a half inch every 100 years it's also
kind of translucent uh it's made of
calcium carbonate but if you hold the
flashlight up to it like that isn't that
cool oh wow
kind of reminds me of
like the
himalayan salt lamp oh yeah yeah
so this is beautiful we're coming up on
our mirror pool here our mirror pull is
what's called a rim pole you ever heard
of that before i have none okay a rim
pole is formed when constant dripping
water hits the ground and pushes away
the sediment causing a little rim
they're really small at first and when
hundreds and then thousands of them just
get bigger and bigger they end up
forming something as large as our mirror
pool here this is beautiful isn't it
yeah
all right well we've got a lot more to
see so let's go
so now we're entering the hall of dreams
hall of dreams yeah it's actually legend
that ruby leo lambert's wife this was
her favorite spot in the cave so much so
that she would come down here to sketch
and daydream if you look directly above
you you'll see all these thousands of
baby stalactites that are nicknamed soda
straws actually
because in their infancy they are hollow
in the middle so the waterfall is just
ahead shall we oh yeah all right
oh i think i hear it
there it is welcome to ruby falls
that is
amazing so
cool thing this room that we're in is
called solomon's temple and it's
believed that the waterfall carved out
this room started at this end and worked
its way back over millions of years and
they call it solomon's temple just
because of its grandeur and beauty yes
grandeur and beauty this is spectacular
so right now we've come just under a
half mile
okay and we are a total of 1120 feet
under the summit of lookout mountain
that is breathtaking yeah and it's cool
to think that
people live up there and this is just
below their feet and they have no idea
yeah i had no idea this is spectacular
and right here in the u.s yep right in
our backyard
what's your favorite thing about coming
down my favorite thing is just every
time i come down here i see something
new yeah be it in the rock formations or
just in the look on people's faces yeah
and
and again that just makes the job worth
it to me thank you for showing me that's
been my pleasure
i gotta ask yeah before i leave can i
take one of these home with me of course
we have these for sale in our gift shop
they're very stylish who knows when i'm
gonna come upon
another waterfall in a cave
[Music]
i had such an amazing time at ruby falls
and to think how long it took leo to
trek through that cave for the first
time and come across that waterfall is
such an incredible visual and just gets
my imagination ignited
chattanooga has been incredible but i'm
curious where we're going next
i think i see a clue that might point us
in that direction
time to build music in the city hmm i
know how to make music i'm not sure what
build music means but i am very curious
to find out what it's all about
tune in next time